[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
famed criminal defense attorney effly
bailly dies our interview with him
just weeks ago about his time
representing o.j simpson at trial
and who he believed really killed nicole
brown simpson and ron goldman
if the defendant had no opportunity to
commit the crime
case over right then two teens accused
of firing at deputies in florida
the 12 year old boy appearing in court
as the 14 year old girl
recovers in a hospital and the
heartbreaking testimony
in the tennessee trial of a father
accused of murdering his five-year-old
autistic son
was joseph daniels angry and violent
like the prosecution claims
or did he give a false confession joe
dead
joe dead joe dead
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the legal world has lost a giant
criminal defense attorney athlete bailly
has died he was 87. law on crime's
angina levy spoke with bayley recently
and has more on his life and a theory
about one of his most well-known clients
yeah brian i spoke with etheley bailey
in one of his last
interviews just in the last several
weeks as you mentioned
we talked about a new book he's written
about the o.j simpson case
i didn't lose any sleep as to what the
decision would be
that was f lee bailey discussing the
case that made him a household name
he represented cleveland doctor sam
shepard at the u.s supreme court
in 1966 shepard v maxwell was a landmark
case that established guidelines for
pre-trial publicity
the high court found shepard's first
trial had a carnival-like atmosphere
in a second trial the jury acquitted
shepard in the murder of his pregnant
wife
marilyn the justice who wrote the
opinion in the shepherd case and told me
later on that he took it right out of my
brief and i should be proud
as i left the room i thought i picked up
a wig
coming off his bench bailey would go on
to represent heiress patty hearst
against charges she robbed a bank
suspected boston strangler albert
desalvo and perhaps most famously
o.j simpson people who came up to me
and said you know you're a great lawyer
but you prostituted
your talents getting that end guy off
and people who said that to me shouldn't
have been i'm talking about lawyers and
in one case
a judge bailey wrote a book about his
time representing simpson that will come
out in a matter of days
the truth about the o.j simpson trial by
the architect of the defense
bailly's cross-examinations were
legendary after all of these years
bailey maintains simpson as factually
innocent of the murders of his ex-wife
nicole brown simpson
and ron goldman there was no opportunity
and we showed that and the record is
very clear
with a timeline showing where everybody
was
at certain times simpson could not
have committed those murders and then
gotten on that airplane
to chicago it's that simple bailly
believed drug dealers targeting a friend
of nicole brown simpsons
faye resnick over a drug death killed
nicole and ron goldman simply happened
upon the scene while returning a pair of
glasses
and i think someone came to that home
and was seen a witness we never got to
use
but is in the book to be sure saw
nicole talking angrily with some people
on the street the jury didn't hear that
theory but acquitted simpson
he posted on twitter about his friend
lee was
like i guess about 87 years old but
boy was he full of energy i mean i mean
i would tell him
lee i got to go to bed i got to go uh uh
and lee would be
up the next morning ready to hit the
streets
but f lee bailey was a great guy after
representing simpson bailey's life took
a sad turn
he was disbarred in florida and
massachusetts but still worked as a
consultant
and had strong opinions about the
justice system
our justice system not only is not
terribly
good when it's compared to many outside
this country
but it's not getting any better and it's
not under control
ethely bailly died just seven days
before what would have been his 88th
birthday he was incredibly excited about
his new book coming out
and we had actually talked about getting
together yet again over zoom to talk
about it in more detail
sadly though that wasn't meant to be
brian
thanks ange joining us today is former
federal prosecutor gene rossi and terry
austin
gene factually innocent not just not
guilty what do you think of ethylene
bailey's alternative theory
it doesn't work there was dna in the
truck
uh he had a cut on his finger he had the
famous bronco
ride where that shows consciousness of
guilt
uh if o.j simpson were innocent his
actions and the evidence the dna
sure did not point towards innocence all
right
now terry representative countless
people a giant in many ways
when you think of f lee bailey what
comes to mind to you
uh what's his legacy i think his legacy
is the fact that he was
an incredible litigator there's no
question about it he was flamboyant
he made points that people will never
forget and obviously the o.j simpson
trial was one of those trials
the biggest thing that he did in that
trial was he cross-examined the
detective mark furman
and he got him to swear understanding he
never used
the n-word and of course that dream team
was able to show that he had
in fact used the word so that meant he
wasn't credible and i think that had a
lot to do
with the volt you know verdict at the
end of the day
now andre we saw a little bit of of o.j
there speaking about athlete bailly
but did bailey stay in touch with his
fellow dream team lawyers
yeah to our knowledge he stayed in touch
with alan dershowitz not really clear
about a lot of the others he famously
had a falling out with robert shapiro
who was the lead attorney
in the very beginning of the case but
then johnny cochran took over that role
he had been friends with robert shapiro
for decades
and after this case they had a huge
falling out so
there was definitely no love lost there
and i've read the first chapter of the
book
and um he has some pretty critical words
for robert shapiro in it
yeah well like we said a giant in the
legal community has been lost
and of course we send our condolences
thank you everyone still ahead on law
and crime daily
what happened to baby joe what the
missing five-year-old sibling told an
investigator
as a father stands trial for murder but
first
the shocking video as two florida teens
face charges for shooting out law
enforcement
we break down the first court appearance
of a 12 year old boy ahead
[Music]
welcome back a 12 year old boy charged
with attempted murder of law enforcement
appeared in court in florida the local
sheriff says the boy along with a 14
year old girl broke out of a foster home
and engaged in a shootout with deputies
appears a female has a long gun pointed
toward me i have to
hold my cover stand by deputies in
florida took cover responding to a
report
of a home broken into a 14 year old girl
and 12 year old boy
reportedly escaped their foster home and
found another home with ak-47s and 200
rounds of ammunition
juvenile male looks like he has
something in his hand as well according
to the sheriff the deputies took fire
for 45 minutes
and only returned fire when the 14 year
old exited the house and continued to
fire
put the guns down now
and and i believe in my heart she's
still alive today because of the first
treatment she received from the deafness
obviously she received great health and
hospital care
but those deputies were reacting as
quickly as they could on thursday the
12-year-old boy made his first
appearance in court on charges
of armed burglary and attempted murder
the judge ordered the boy be held in
secured attention
until his arraignment on june 23rd he
advised that the 14 year old made a
statement
i'm going to roll this down like gta
referring to the video game grand theft
auto the sheriff described the two teens
as bonnie and clyde
and said the 12 year old boy told
investigators he fired to harm cops
the boy does not have a criminal record
but the girl was arrested in april
for setting fire to empty lots and the
sheriff says the foster home
is a known problem function has been a
problem since i've been the sheriff for
probably beyond we were there 289 times
for calls for service
and 220. we've been there 89 times so
far
this year back with us is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
terry according to the police these two
were shot at officers from the pool deck
the bedroom the garage
based on severity of these crimes and
their age do you think they'll be tried
as minors or adults
well i think that it's up to the state
attorney's office to determine that
question
listen the seriousness of this crime
it's a capital offense there's no
question they could be here
and they were using ak-47s they are
children the 12-year-old boy appeared in
court and the judge was explaining his
rights to him and
clearly this child is someone who
is going to have to go through a system
that is intended for adults
so i think that the authorities are
going to have to look at this very
carefully before they make that final
determination
now gene that focuses on the 12 and the
14 year old but could an investigation
go beyond just the shooting
like how they broke out of foster care
and how those guns were properly stored
or not stored properly well you're
talking about whether the foster or a
home
has criminal or civil liability i think
the foster home may have civil liability
for whatever victim want to bring suit
against that
regarding criminal liability against the
foster home
that would be a stretch you'd have to
show
some kind of criminal negligence and i
don't know if you'd have that
exactly i definitely think the criminal
might be a bit of a stretch
but civil gene just really quickly maybe
the officers who got shot at
maybe they can say hey you should have
kept these kids in line because then i'm
the one who's risking my life could that
be potential
oh absolutely and if any of those
officers had died
those families and of the victims the
officers
they could have filed a wrongful death
suit against the foster home for
negligence
yeah that would have been uh thankfully
none of the officers died from what we
understand the charges
are merely attempted murder no one was
hit or harmed other than the 14 year old
who's recovering but
thank you both for that input let's
check in on some top legal stories
making headlines at the law and crime
network
including an ohio judge denying a motion
for a mistrial in the so-called pizza
delivery murder
erika stefanko was convicted of placing
a fake pizza order at domino's to lure
ashley biggs to her death
stefanko's then-husband chad cobb was in
a heated custody battle with biggs
cobb pled guilty to the murder of biggs
and helped to implicate stefanko
taking the stand against her sifenko's
defense attorney says
she wasn't given a fair trial due to
limitations during the pandemic
and in california explosive testimony
came from robert durst's former
housekeeper who claims she saw blood on
a dishwasher
after the disappearance of durst's first
wife kathy in 1982.
the real estate airs on trial for
allegedly shooting and killing
his lifelong friend susan berman in
december 2000
witnesses are being called in relation
to his wife kathy durst because the
prosecution case
rests on two points one susan berman
witnessed the crime of kathy durst
presumed murder
and was intentionally killed because of
that two
robber durst killed berman by lying in
weight at her home waiting for the right
moment to kill her
durst defense says he didn't kill berman
and doesn't know who did
doris is expected to take the stand in
his own defense the trial could last
up to six months testimony is set to
resume on monday
retired tulsa police sergeant sean
stakes-larkin is speaking to a former
swat team member
about a hosta situation on the latest
episode of his podcast
cocktails all right you're working for
atf with this home invasion
and these guys are robbing the cartel
yeah
that's stupid it doesn't end well for
you at all
um so they said hey this guy's these
guys are
have committed several murders we want
you to go undercover and like try to
infiltrate this group and i was like
well i guess this is where i hug my mom
and dad by and i'm
like i love you mom um
so we they had an informant whose family
was doing this
and they made the introduction and
basically these guys were
you know targeting high level cartel
tied drug dealers they'd find out where
their stash house was
kick the door in execute them steal
their dope drive it back down to miami
push it out on the streets
and i was like all right let's do it
interesting story make sure to check out
sean larkin's cocktails podcast
coming up on law and crime daily who is
baby joe
what you need to know about the missing
five-year-old and his father on trial
for his murder
after the break
welcome back we're heading to tennessee
where a father is accused of murdering
his five-year-old son
witnesses are taking the stand painting
a picture of what the young boy was like
he was he was very funny he was very
energetic
he loved to play and he loved to joke
around joseph clyde daniels speech
therapist would work with him
three days a week in kindergarten
the five-year-old boy also known as baby
joe was autistic and working on his
speech and motor skills
he he really took instruction will
he he enjoyed doing the activities that
we were doing
and he was making he made a lot of
progress
he had a lot of potential baby jones was
last seen on april 3
2018 his father joseph ray daniels
reported him as missing the next day
search crews gathered and baby joe's
school bus driver even offered to
shuttle volunteers around
100 percent they were all in for it but
three days later
investigators say daniels confessed to
whipping the boy for urinating on the
floor
prosecutors say daniels then told them
he put the boy outside
and baby joe ran towards the porch the
defendant allegedly brought him back
inside
and slammed his body on the coffee table
the defense says daniels is innocent
and claims baby joe could have left the
home by himself
so he could grasp that door handle if he
wanted to couldn't he
if he wanted to and he could turn that
door handle and open the door couldn't
he
yes daniels led investigators to where
he said he disposed of baby joe's body
but his remains have never been
recovered danny was charged with
first-degree murder
the boy's mother crystal daniels is
charged with aggravated trial neglect
or endangerment in helping to cover up
the crime
g h
when we come back the chilling
conversation overheard by investigators
as they search for the missing
five-year-old boy that testimony and
more
[Music]
next
back now to the trial of joseph daniels
a state investigator
says he arrived at the home to collect
information about the missing
five-year-old boy
when the three-year-old brother of baby
joe walked in
saying this into the room that's the
first time i
recall seeing noah you come up to my
right
uh and he stated or asked for
joe dead joe dead
joe dead and um
elder you lady that was there in the
room with us
uh said yes baby joe did
i want to make sure i get this clear
were you asking questions of noah
no he just entered the room he entered
from the
back and on my right asking this
that three times yeah he walked in and
three times
said joe dead yes joe did yes joe did
yes
and you in your testimony is that what
happened after that
uh the elderly lady and joyce
said yes baby joe did
and then she picked the she reached down
and
picked up picked up noah yeah
okay on cross the defense asked if the
three-year-old statements of joe dead
change the investigation in any way it
was being coordinated at the property
if you're facing the house to the right
so there's a significant number of
people
at the area yes it was said in two or
three different ways here but
when noah came in to talk to aunt joycey
he asked her he didn't ask
her he asked he just asked
out yes he wasn't directly asking if
he's dead
yeah at that point
had you witnessed anyone discussing the
possibility
that with joe missing at that period he
had been that he would be deceased
no sir we were still under some strength
we had a missing child
so would it be possible that sometime
during the six hours of searching that
that would have been discussed
but not by me in this trial the jury's
allowed to ask questions after
every testifying witness the jury had
one key one key question
about the phrase three-year-old noah
said
all right i have two questions from the
jurors
first question is did mr perceive noah's
words as a question or a statement
the second is was the tractor-trailer
ever searched
uh clearly the second one of those is a
question that's legitimate
and i don't have a problem with it um
either
side wish to be heard about whether or
not i should or should not ask that
question
let's start with mr morris perceiving
the noah's words as a question or a
statement
well what i'm proposing to do is to
bring the jury back and make sure they
understand that the first question was
asked and answered by mr mitchell
uh and mr morris right before we sent
him out the second question
i'm going to ask him if he knows
personally but i'll let them know that
there will be further evidence on that
issue
all right let's bring gene and terry
back in one last time gene this is a new
one for me
jurors get to question the witness what
did you make of the
this rule and the jurors question that
you saw just there
well let's go to the rule i've seen one
trial i think it was in wisconsin
but it is sort of developing that jurors
can ask questions
i like it only if the questions don't
become ridiculous
they don't become voluminous and they
focus on an issue that hasn't already
been addressed
so going to the questions given to the
judge whether
uh the baby or the three-year-old noah
asked the question or made a statement
that was answered so that should not be
asked by
by the judge the other question i
thought was good but the prosecution
seems uh that they are prepared to
answer that question
in upcoming uh presentation of witnesses
so i like i like it
yeah so do i it kind of also gives the
lawyers i think a gauge as to
where are they thinking what are they
looking at and maybe they can adapt and
and alter
future questions to help guide the jury
what they want
terry the judge ruled that statements
made by the brother
and the aunt were allowed if it is
hearsay why is the judge allowing the
statements in
you know judge wolf is very considerate
when he makes these decisions he takes
the time to think about it he even cites
cases and the statement that you heard
on the stand from agent brent morris he
was from the emergency management
agency he said he actually heard noah
come out
and say joe dead joe dead joe dead three
times and he
heard the aunt say yes noah is dead
and that would normally be hearsay but
the exception to that
is the excited utterance and the judge
explained in great detail
why this was an excited utterance even
though the actual event did not occur
the whole event in totality with all of
the agencies who were
at the home that was the event and so
this is still an excited utterance
yeah and as an exception to hearsay that
comes in and that's why the jury hear it
gene terry thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you